because I think there is an emergency
happening funny funny stop there's
nobody there is an emergency me and
these is offering you guys percent off
your first pair if you use me and Nizam
/gen and Julian or click the link in the
description guys you heard me talk about
me and ease alright this sustainably
sourced ultra soft underwear that will
change your life gets them today 20% off
using a discount code I'm taking new
training classes and trying to have my
eyes be independent of each other so
that one can be reading the skin well
okay it's it condenses all the top
stories and sends it right to an email
every morning with all like all the
stuff you need to know so you have the
stuff in your email to be informed in a
condensed readable fashion it's not
cluttered it's on the internet it's not
questionable it's all the facts all you
need to know right there what's
happening in the world right now is
completely free just go do this skim
that's th tsk IMM comm slash Jenna
Julianne and you can enter for a chance
to win 20 $50 Visa gift card that's also
free entering very chance win that but
it's literally just a newsletter you
subscribe doesn't cost a thing so check
it out or click link thank you sponsors
okay stop
well I really we're completely exhausted
which is why it's like the more tired we
are like the goofier this gets don't
it's not
panic button it's the bottom of the
table stop doing it
that was a shocker oh okay there's I'm
like so tired like everything is so
bright right now like are you are you
guys sick of us telling you how tired we
are
yeah I'm just we pa1 taking that no we
tired
um I hate this but we're doing it for a
specific reason that we're not telling
you it's going on we're just tired with
all the [ __ ] that's going on right now
you guys will know everything soon it's
not a big deal but yeah we it's been
pretty exhausting our our work schedule
has been extra difficult lately yeah my
mom was just here the machine was in
town which was fun but hosting is
hosting right so it's like you know with
Mother's Day yeah it was Mother's Day
and we uh her tradition we all came over
to our house yep a some food relaxed
yeah yeah happy Mother's Day happy
Mother's Day I hope you guys had a
wonderful Mother's Day yesterday for you
and ate some chocolate and hunted for
some egg nope sorry I'm sorry
well I mean you could have done that too
happy Mother's Day and then you throw
her in Easter party hey and he surprised
by the no party I never said that the
Easter Bunny who was also a mother who
didn't get anything from Mother's Day
we've got all of her presents on Easter
and then said hey I'm also a mother
mother first in the Easter Bunny second
I thought it would be a fun idea you
guys were always I mean Jenna did this
when I was unable to be on the podcast
she did sort of an advice podcast where
you guys would ask her well that was
part of it you did a lot of things you
were a man a man of who wears many hats
did you intentionally misgender me and
you're a funny guy Thanks well I thought
you guys have tweeted us if you know
questions that we can give you advice on
life things every week I would say
anytime we asked for suggestions that's
probably one of the top ones is you guys
asking yeah you guys always want advice
as if we're in any position to give
anybody advice I don't know man I'm I
don't know life any better than anybody
else no you don't I really don't there
are a few of these i screen shot in a
bunch of them but there are a few of
them that i think we can give you at
least sort of our experience it's all
anecdotal right like we're not experts
nobody is we just we just live our life
so we'll give you our advice on some of
these things and maybe I'll give you
some bad advice because I think you guys
were looking for some bad advice - I'm
never looking for bad I am capable of
delivering the content in the form of
that advice get that checked out what my
foot yeah it's called the foot Julien
attached to my leg I don't need to get
it I got a guy at Sports Chalet Hills
close down there well you think it's
been a front for all these years
a guy fixing toes what's wrong with my
toes it's beautiful but I can get it all
I can give you a guide oh okay check
come up they're fine the toes don't book
away let's get started
oh no that's gonna be one of these isn't
it I don't know what you are talking I
already feel like hot and not ready I
wish you guys would calm down over there
it's just a lot I thought it was
multiple people it's not like an angry
mob I now realize it's just you okay
okay Krista Deen Krista asked how to get
into a regular workout routine just just
start running and don't stop you'll get
where you need to go you'll burn all the
calories at every corner of the streets
there will be someone handing out cups
of Pedialyte depending on the
neighborhood you're running that changes
the flavor of Pedialyte some honestly
some neighborhoods are really shitty
because they've watered down there
they're pedia and then others are
they give bigger cups did you just tell
her to just start running the weight and
literally start running it'll figure
itself a way to get into regular
exercises to just start running out of
pure necessity and survival yes as if
you were being cheap chased okay chase
yeah cool okay no for serious I feel
like I could speak to this a little bit
[Music]
first of all I don't know so every
working out for every person your feet
are on my lap it feels good it's why I
wanna what was that noise
then her dog guys are you okay what's
going on over there
sounds like a moan yeah what the heck
dude shut up dude working out is
different for everyone right so like
some people have a background at sports
some people have a background in not
sports and just kind of normal athletic
training has a person at the gym who
runs on the treadmill lifts their
weights and found their routine however
they found it and I don't I I definitely
don't believe there's one routine or one
type of routine that works for everyone
like like workout routine is a very
customized thing it's very personal so I
think it comes down to like two parts
for me one is finding a routine that
works for you in terms of like the style
of working out like you like it you have
to like it
is it lifting weights is it Pilates is
it yoga is it a sport is it jujitsu is
it volleyball is it softball you know we
find out a workout routine that you
enjoy but it also pushes you and you
know those two things kind of come can't
hand hand to make it the routine that
you like in terms of this style of
working out and once you found that and
you you don't ever have to feel like
you've nailed that down because that
changes like has people change and grow
you change in your interest change so
whatever for the time being that is your
interest I would I would chase that as
your workout routine and then just find
a way to not make it monotonous right
there's ways to have you know you split
you split your workout schedule so
you're not doing the same thing every
day or every week you can kind of make
it a big one two three four
week split so that each week is
different from the next and then you
start the cycle over and maybe you can
modify it the next time or something
like that if you're looking for
traditional weightlifting or traditional
like basic gym stuff to do there's
plenty of information out there for like
basic workouts and stuff and even people
who will write you workouts on a
customized basis there's like online
coaching that really isn't crazy
expensive there are options out there
that help you kind of formulate your own
workout plan but I definitely think the
first part is the most important where
you find what you're interested in and
something that's sustainable and Kay and
you know it's doable there's this place
near you to do it or whatever even more
beginner than that though like if you're
someone that's never worked out like
your that you've never been to a gym
you've never had a gym membership or you
don't play tennis or you know a sport
where there's other people pick 10
minutes or 20 minutes something small
during the day and pick a schedule for
that like give yourself maybe a couple
days of rest to begin with her three-day
you know whatever it is but make an
actual schedule and for those 10 minutes
just try and break a sweat however you
can maybe that's going for a walk one
day or doing 100 sit-ups one day or
whatever like I feel like it's just
creating the habit before even finding
something that you're like I love this
and I want to do this and this makes me
happy because for a lot of people like
me like I like lifting weights but
that's about it like I like softball but
I don't really want to play in a co-ed
league it's a form of exercise it's just
not enough for me you know there's just
not enough softball games takes up a
little bit too much time and energy I
feel like it's not that realistic but
like I like walking but I'm not a yoga
person I'm not like a Pilates person it
might take you a long time to figure out
what you like so in the meantime give
yourself a schedule and make them small
amounts of time and don't give yourself
excuses to skip that like obviously
they're an asset like necessary things
in life when you can't do it but even if
you're traveling or you know you got a
really long day you're feeling a little
sick like you can do something even if
it's stretching that day or something
like that to get you in the habit of
doing it on a day
basis great noise yeah I totally agree
and also I think something really
important too is figuring out what time
of day you like to work out it because
when I was younger like in college if I
had the choice to do it at 5:00 a.m. it
would always get done at 5:00 yeah yeah
but like now that I'm older I'm like
let's work out in the mid afternoon we
work out at the laziest hour I feel like
that could change in life like right now
does change it every time your luxury of
being like okay it's 4:00 p.m. let's go
work yeah a couple years ago didn't work
for either of us absolutely
great points I also forgot one thing
that I think is super important that
when you find something that you like as
a as a fitness regiment
keep notes dedicate a little book get a
little mini notebook and just write
notes whether it's your logging all of
your workouts or just different things
that are working in that things that
aren't or just just write down your
experience like for me that is one of
the most helpful things in being an
athletic person is keeping logs of
things and I'm not talking about this is
a personal thing I mean this and I'm not
talking about like being like crazy you
know religiously writing down everything
that I do because that's I feel like
that's a little much but some of my I've
kept like most of my old notebooks and
little workout notebooks from high
school college whatever and I have them
still and I can see the workouts I was
doing and it's something is really cool
about that because it's like a cool way
to like log and remember your progress
and how you wrote down your workouts and
Jiu Jitsu is even more important you
write down different notes that are
things that are helping you and things
like that I just think having a little
notebook a little fitness notebook is a
good thing to have no matter how often
you writing it just having it has an
option yeah to kind of keep you thing I
don't know if I said this cuz I just
forgot because I'm tired but like
something I always remind people when
they ask me stuff like that is exercise
is free exercises is literally free as
free as free as free is free it's free
if you want to pay money for it in some
way shape or form you absolutely can but
moving your body is free and there's
plenty of like you can just look up [ __ ]
on Instagram for for workouts you can do
so fun a tiny room you can do yoga in a
tiny room you could do it like anything
that you want in a tiny room yeah moving
your body is free
and so don't ever let let that stop you
from accomplishing what you want to
accomplish good point Jack I don't think
you could become a professional power
lifter without weights but you know you
could certainly keep your body in mind
in shape
I don't think think Krista was looking
into being a professional pilot there
but if she was options if you are
forgive me will will probably need some
weights for that maybe maybe not
what if the guys just like one
powerlifting competitions just from
doing push-ups Holly dink Holly it's
like a team like you guys all have dink
before your name dink Holly on Twitter
how to transition into supporting
yourself and no longer relying on
parents mine was pretty fast and not a
choice yeah so like go ahead well mine
was like by the time we're done you know
in high school we don't live there like
there were a couple of summers or some
high school you don't get high school so
after I saw that sentences confusion
sorry
no after high school like once I'm off
to college like there were a couple
summers when I was still working at day
camp in Rochester but after that it was
like get the [ __ ] out and then after
college it was super like don't call me
there is no help here like unless a
disaster happened like you're on your
own I think if that if that is the
precedent that someone has set for you
like about as a parent then it's easy
because I think I think it's easy
because there's not really an option I
think the hard the hard answer is like
when it's an option to stay at home how
do you get out mmm right I could speak
to that a little bit I guess I don't
know I mean I just think that there
comes a point in your life where you may
not know exactly what you want to do
like as a career or with your life or
even as hobby it's like you may just
kind of be floating whether you finish
school or you're in school or whatever
but there comes a point when you reach
like you know a teen or early 20s or
whatever
where you're like okay there's a choice
to make here like I can spend my time
doing something that's that's easy and
maybe available to me like staying at a
parents house or you know whatever or
you can maybe step a little bit outside
the box of comfort you can get a job
that multiple jobs or jobs that require
you to be like in the workplace you
could get your own small apartment in a
less than convenient location get a
roommate find some on Craigslist
whatever and all of that sound most most
likely less less appealing than staying
at home but I think that choice is a
really important one because even though
it's not as convenient or easy that is
the step that you take into being a real
adult and it's gonna help you and it
helped me a lot when I when I sort of
made a similar choice right like I don't
know I feel like a lot of my friends and
a lot of people I know didn't make that
choice you know and I think they they
weren't exposed to opportunities certain
opportunities that I was yeah because I
did I had just started like after
college because college was so busy and
then I did my masters so fast like that
was so busy like by the time I reached
adulthood I always had so many jobs at
once you know what I mean like this was
a carefully formatted plan to make sure
that I always had my rent covered and my
expenses covered but even then you're
talking about
I had a wiggle room of a hundred to two
hundred dollars depending on tips like
literally bartending or go-go dancing
like you might have some extra one but
not a lot like that's my expendable
income for the month like the quicker
you learn how to budget your money in
your time the better like if you are
living with someone who's supporting you
financially like there's so many reasons
why people would do that please know
that I'm not talking to you like people
that have sick parents or they're just
doing it because it's like a little
easier like I'm not talking down on
anybody that lives with their parents
but I am saying if you want that to be
an easier transition if you have the
choice to move out or something like
that not the people that don't have
choices that
live your life fine you find but
learning how to budget your own money so
that like when you do live on your own
you are taking into account like I can't
buy all the food that's in my mom's
refrigerator I can't like drive my car
because I'm using my mom made my mom's
car my mom's credit card to pay for gas
or car insurance or health insurance
like yeah get another job or like start
saving your money to give yourself a
bubble of income or saved money so that
you can pay for your expenses in the
future you know I mean like it's not I
wish it was as easy as we'll all move
out someday when I have enough money
because I feel like I know so many
people like that and that's an easy
rational rationalization for people who
want to stay at home right like that's
what they are telling them I'll slide
the moon when I have enough money you
know it's a two-way thing though I mean
certain situations enable that option
right like the parents that hold the
whole situation can make that a
possibility which may seem convenient at
the time but I definitely think that
after a certain point it is detrimental
I agree well because it it becomes
comfortable and that I can't tell you
how many people my age that I knew
however many years ago that we're like
I'm just gonna move home for a few years
and save money and then I'm gonna buy a
condo like if I had a dollar for every
time I heard one of my friends say that
is like insane none of them ever
actually accomplished that because what
happens when you're not correctly
budgeting the money that you do have
you're not saving money yeah cuz I'm
like how's living at home going you
saving a bunch of money or what's going
on and it just turns into yeah but then
you know you just sort of lose track of
where your money's going and they
haven't saved anything really since
being there you know and those are full
adults those are like 24 25 26 27 year
olds that make that decision and still
don't execute it as well as they'd like
to so for an 18 or 19 year old like no
one's expecting you to be perfect at it
but it's a really good way to like
become an adult and stay an adult you
don't mean
just just making the move out of your
parents house when it's less than
convenient or it's a little bit
difficult yeah we'll help you right most
and also you'll I think you'll have a
lot of opportunities where you could
call your parents and be like I need
some help like I need some money listen
okay I'm not suggesting this now cuz I
think it's a little bit different but
when I was younger I was literally every
single Monday I would scrub Craigslist I
would scrub models model mayhem or
whatever that was like I would scrub any
website where I could go literally just
do freelance work for a couple of hours
that week and earn an extra 20 60 80
$100 and that's the difference between
you calling someone because you're short
on your phone bill and not you know what
I mean
like if there's an opportunity in your
neighborhood or you could pets it or you
could babysit or you know there's a lot
of things that you could do with your
time to earn that little extra money to
where you wouldn't have to call someone
to help you you don't mean so that you
also don't get evicted or like fall
behind on your payments or whatever it
is you got going on because I don't do
that either
yeah but you have to make ends meet yeah
and you guys are smart as [ __ ] man you
really smart all of you guys so use that
to your advantage get crafty with it you
know yeah don't feel like you have to do
things certain way because other people
do them that way all right that's what I
would do
I'm like I'm literally gonna be 80
dollars short I better find somebody
that needs a [ __ ] cat sitter and they
need him now I babysat I when I was in
college I worked the fit I had something
called work-study which is like a you
know student a student what does it call
it [ __ ] it's like part of your
scholarship it's like a work program
with him whatever fine auntie was part
of financially and so I had a couple
jobs one of them was just like work in
the fitness center which was such a joke
it's like student fitness centers
especially like ours was really shitty
like sign into the gym sign it
you don't have to deal with anything
ever you know it's a lot different now I
actually visited a couple years ago it's
like totally [ __ ] different but I
worked that job I worked in the athletic
department I
when you're in college though when you
know I know a little different no I know
I'm just saying like these are jobs like
wow in college it is different it is
because it's a lot more easy and
contained or whatever and available but
I would pick up weekend shifts all the
time because they paid like time and a
half because people didn't want you know
honor that is a loophole okay yeah but I
did that to make extra money like you
said like it's you have to find ways no
I was saying that that students would
get paid time and a half on the weekend
I feel like there's a little bit of a
loophole well cuz no one wanted to work
on the weekend especially like the
nights I didn't go to parties I was like
give me a defendants interview all right
um you want to pick the next one I don't
know you did the first two grief
just give me one grief are going through
hard times by Maddie that's not a
question
advice oh nice yeah we can I mean we
have to ah
well for me anytime I'm going through
something it's really difficult to
remember but that it is temporary that
it will get fixed you know not fixed but
like the way that you're feeling is
incredibly heavy and that heaviness will
get better and I know in that moment
it's like I can't I can't wait for it to
get better like it feels awful now you
know what I mean trying the best to make
sure that you are okay like it's okay to
sit with your sadness and your feelings
and everything that is going on but that
you do your best to make sure you are
okay and if you are not okay that you
need to get help to get okay but that it
will also pass or get better in some way
that it is a temporary state the actual
state of grief it's perfect can't even
top that it's hard to be cognizant of
that though when you're hysterical you
know of course but and like that's not
to say you shouldn't go through morning
and go through sadness and crying and
all the emotions because that's part of
it but when you get to the point where
you're questioning you know like why is
this so hard like will it stop like I
hate this like what you know what I mean
just know that time does help
and that like he said that's one thing
that right now in the moment it's the
hardest thing to comprehend
there was one in here one of the hit how
to okay Clark after dark do you want to
read this one so as advice on how to
seamlessly ended Julian read it please
finishing want to seamlessly integrate
that sponsor spot and right now guys
check out me and ease because they have
this office underwear and they sponsor
the podcast you can get 20% off your
first pair when you go to me undies comm
slash Jenna they have three times softer
than cotton made of micro modal
sustainably sourced fabric new designs
each month shipped right to your door
you can have a subscription where you
have cool underwear showing up at your
house because who needs cool people at
your house just get cool underwear your
house guys I talk about it all the time
and I don't only talk about it I wear
about it I'm wearing the undies right
now every single day I wear me undies
every single day I wear me on these guys
every single day and they actually just
released a super soft pants they're like
lounge pants they're great for leisure
in as you guys some of you guys like to
please you're ready so I would check out
their collection you will be blown away
the first time you try some underwear
from me undies just go to me undies it's
m-e UND IES comm slash annejulien get
20% off first pair and I'm mad at you
just be the just be the [ __ ] with your
man you also should be in the know with
all of what's happening in the world
with this skin guys the skin is a daily
newsletter that comes in to your email
inbox in a really nice concise
well-put-together fashion so that you
can know what's going on in the world
without any of the nonsense that
surrounds information online nowadays
okay you can know the top stories you
can know what people are talking about
what people are mimin okay so you have
the base in for me
and then you'll need for that day and
you do with it as you choose right you
can be ahead of the curve at the
watercooler okay you can be the quickest
Mimar on twitter okay well I just
sounded like a goddamn grandfather the
skim is a really great way to get your
information in a no-nonsense fashion
okay Oh God
right now go to this game that's th e s
ki mmm that's two M's calm / shadow
Julian enter your email and click
Subscribe that is it you're gonna get an
email the next morning and you're gonna
see what I mean it is great you also get
a chance to enter for a two hundred and
fifty dollar Visa gift card when you
sign up and subscribe to the skin get
your foot out of my face that's
disgusting
stop it get some help guys reading the
news like an old guy like me is
time-consuming okay hop on the skin and
get in the know now I want you to get
out cut I'm not reading any more
questions I don't trust you violated my
trust how to fold a fitted sheet first
step you're gonna take I'm gonna address
it you just completely betrayed my trust
and a betray yes you did bamboozled you
you helped me at the sponsor babe I
don't want to meet boozled you got
boozled folding a fitted sheet so you're
gonna take it like this no don't say
your own no and you're gonna reach out
really wide and when you look up to the
sky with arms right oh but we'll start
playing by Creed in the background
really loud it's gonna start raining
your bedroom and once the sheet gets wet
you just fold it really fast and then
it's perfect and then you wake up and
don't do that drug agenda oh my god how
do not procrastinate figure it out later
it's funny as a procrastination to boot
okay serious answer to this if you're in
a really procrastinating mood whether
it's for homework work work [ __ ] around
the house cleaning organizing
getting your car cleaned getting your
toe clean to her look that there's
something wrong with my toe rest my
thigh something that works for me is
anytime you enter a new room in the
house why are you breathing like that
are you mocking me are you mocking my
breath pattern don't do that make sure
every single time you enter and exit a
room one thing gets done in that room
even if it's the tiniest thing like you
pick up a piece of trash and throw it
out or if you walk into your your your
room where you do desk your desk where
your do homework really would you like
to hear the Virgo version of that every
time you walk into a room it looks
perfect and every time you walk out of a
room you make sure you leave it the same
way you found it that's an insane way no
it's just not realistic guys that's not
procrastination though
[Laughter]
procrastination for me I feel like the
only thing that helps is a reward system
like I only work on rewards so like
you're a dog yeah cuz like it's just not
it always gets done but like I'm not
gonna do it and this I have something to
look forward to by doing it that's good
that's good
so like when I was younger and I like I
took piano for a lot of years and every
time that I played one correctly I would
get a magical friend right I had three
little you know [ __ ] figurines on the
top of my piano every time every time I
played it perfectly I would get to move
one tone you know to like the top of the
keys and I'm like yay only two more
perfect times until I'm done practicing
sounds
it's very sad but what it does is it
teaches you like I get a little reward
you know it wasn't for you know doing
well or something yeah so like for me a
lot of times like this isn't this
shouldn't be news to you but like I do
procrastinate on Wednesdays when we're
making my video like a lot cuz I can't
there's a lot of reasons why like just
generally busy it takes a long time like
everything but sometimes I can't decide
which direction I want to go in so I'm
like you know if I figure it out and I
you know sort of suss stuff out this is
a different conversation but like when
I'm ready to get going I could sort of
like lollygag and go through my hand for
a while and then decide that I'm hungry
and I need to eat it all sounds exactly
correct but if I want to play
hearthstone I'm not allowed to play
hearthstone at all during the day ever
until my video is done uploaded
everything a lot like pub G like if I
want to play pub G obviously I can't sit
and play pub G in the middle of day on
Wednesday like try not to play video
games in the middle of the day unless
it's the weekend we're streaming on a
scheduled day for sure but like they're
no fun until all of your work is done
basically if I rant
yeah no fine until all of your work is
done no watching a TV show no well I
like to I like to change that a little
fun as your work goes on no that doesn't
work for a little so for me kind of
recently when I would go so the last
minute trips I added those episodes and
when we come back we're [ __ ]
exhausted and I have like that week
Monday through Friday or sometimes
Tuesday through Friday depending on when
we get back to edit and I know that
Friday we're releasing the episode we've
announced it it's yeah it's a deadline
but you know on the heels of travel and
I'm getting back in your normal routine
and all that [ __ ] you're exhausted and
you don't I knew you want to chill so
for me I would go like in the timeline I
would date okay when I reach when I
finished editing the intro sequence okay
I'm gonna take an editing break and I'm
gonna play a couple rounds of pub G or
I'm gonna take anything break I'm gonna
go make some food or I'm taking anybody
walk the dogs go to gym whatever not go
to the gym just kidding I know that's
was fun and then it'll be like okay once
I get to the
nine minute times you know I mean like
just a little bit each time because that
way every time I go back to it I feel
like oh god I don't feel like that
stress of like oh my god I've so much to
do I'd be like well I'm glad I pushed
myself the last like round right you
know and then it slowly gets done and
then then you have a product you know
it's people who have to write essays or
papers or study I feel like that can
work in a similar fashion right Oh for
me like when I was in school and I was
studying or writing papers writing
papers in particular like I was always
the type of person that like did it in a
certain order like I wouldn't just sit
down and start just [ __ ] diary [ __ ] I
don't know that paper like I need to
finish a thought before I can be done
for the night yeah I mean yeah like I
would always watch my friends feel like
I'm time gonna take a break I'm gonna
pop out whatever and I'm like you did it
like you didn't finish the the you know
what your hypothesis is or like this
first argument like you can't you can't
just leave halfway through that cuz
you're gonna forget what you're doing
you're gonna be a different headspace
next time you come back like editing is
a lot like writing a paper where like
for me I cannot take a break until the
thought that I'm making is finished do
you mean 100% it translates differently
to each thing but that concept is
universal for sure for sure like if I if
I found a song there like and I want it
for one specific sequence I'm not done
I'm not getting up off the chair until
that you can't like stop halfway through
me like a figure the rest of it yeah you
like you have a thought in a vision and
yeah so like if you're studying like I
don't know how people would get up in
the chapter feel like I'm gonna go have
a margarita you need to finish that
chapter what are you doing margarita so
bad okay we can make you a margarita
your girl whip but yeah anyways
procrastination but really the best
thing that helps me is that knowing or
giving myself like a small reward hold
I'm really at this ease but you do that
boy giving yourself a small reward after
finishing whatever it is I need to do
small reward treat yourself like a dog
but it's not always even ever gonna go
right like a good reward and sometimes
it's like I'm gonna lay on the kitchen
floor and hug my
that's high reward
advice on Benvolio says advice on doing
coffee enemas okay you know no wow it
doesn't seem right butt chugging is
right but you cannot convince me to
shove coffee up my butt
it's just not gonna happen I'm so no
they're just asking for advice on how to
do it
no that's as on doing um potato potato I
say you go for it call my son I mean
it's your body you do whatever you want
but I don't have any advice for you okay
sorry this was this was one that sort of
stuck out to me ah Anna asks advice on
feeling like you're useless I feel like
I lost my motivation to do things that I
like I've been better lately but it's
always in the back of my mind also
advice on living on your own and helpful
tips for a building so the first part of
that is something I think is important
because I think a lot of people go
through that where you lose motivation
and you start to doubt yourself and you
go through phases of sadness and
questioning what you're doing I was like
all those emotions are linked to each
other but they're not the same thing and
they're not necessarily because of each
other true true I think that was like it
yeah that was a packed question for sure
I think one thing that one thing that
helps me when I feel like I don't you
know I feel like I'm not creative or I'm
like doubting my ideas or stuff like
that I like to remember and you can seek
proof of this like by going on YouTube
or going wherever you would admire
certain people and watching videos of
them opening up or seeing accounts of
them being honest about how they go
through the same thing and just knowing
that other people even people that you
might look up to also go through a
similar thing because that for me is
like it humanizes the experience of
being a creative person because when you
see really creative people who do really
great things you think to yourself oh
they're just like incredible and they
just non-stop can go through life and
conquer it and create awesome [ __ ]
but they go through all the same [ __ ]
they just deal with it how they deal
with it but just know that everyone is
that am I like if everyone goes through
that self-doubt it's like a thing that
doesn't escape anyone it just treat you
know everyone kind of deals with it
differently well yeah no I mean I think
all of that is right obviously but in
terms of just if you had that without
the I'm having trouble with motivation
which i think is sometimes a different
thing I don't know how directly linked
it is to you feeling useless but
sometimes in the past when I felt
useless the best way to deal with that
in and of itself it should just go do
something useful help someone else like
if I'm feeling useless as you go go
volunteer for an afternoon you'd be
amazed how surprisingly useful you feel
how helpful and full you feel as a
person to just put yourself out there in
a way that gives you some purpose
honestly like this is so beyond me and
doesn't even matter and like I feel
great for doing it I feel great for
showing up and there's a lot of people
that could use my help or that need help
a lot more than me and you know what I
feel really happy and lucky to be able
to do it just basic stuff when you wake
up with actual like gratitude in your
body that you have like clean air to
breathe and like clean water to drink
and food to eat or maybe an able body or
maybe you don't have any of those like
be thankful for the things that you do
have and if you start out your day with
that type of attitude
if you're feeling useless only in that
sense go see if your neighbor needs you
to shovel their driveway or take the
garbage in like offer yourself in some
way and that feeling does fade away when
you realize that there are people out
there that actually need help and I'm a
useful person but the lack of motivation
is is if it's if that's linked to you
feeling useless so you're like I'm not
good at anything and I suck at
everything so I don't really want to do
anything that again it stems from you
just going out there and realizing that
you don't have to be good in order to do
stuff you don't have to be the best at
anything ever like literally ever you
just have to do you know like that's it
that's all there is to
basically wake up and just do what you
can and then that's about it if you want
to wake up and and do very little that's
fine
like just do the best that you can in
any day I'm giving your current state
but like the motivation will come as
you're feeling better about what you're
doing do you mean yeah because it's not
always based on your ability cuz like
think of all the people in the world
that really want to get in shape right
and those first few times are so [ __ ]
frustrating for people because it's hard
and it physically hurts and it's really
frustrating to do things that your body
is telling you that you can't do you
know it's very easy to get stuck in that
mindset of like I can't do this I just
can't you know and what do you do you
just wake up and you just do just go
back you don't I mean just keep trying
that's all there is
so I mean I don't know your specific
situation but hopefully some of that
helped in some sense if you're just
feeling useless just go make yourself
useful and I think you'd be surprised
how much better you feel and if it's
tied to your motivation just wake up and
do the best that you can and your
motivation will come back as you're
attaching purpose to other things other
than just your ability yet something
that's good you know just put things
into perspective right yeah NYC girl
Lauren Lauren Hawkins Hawkins says
veganism for broke dummies ooh
it's called rice and beans I honestly
you know when I was in college and I was
like pump being really frugal
I wasn't vegan so if eggs the quinoa I
can only I can only kind of give you
thoughts on what I think but Jenna
really went through that so mm-hmm
I think like when you buy in bulk that's
obviously a great start like rice beans
vegetables like China dies first
vegetables get get the grains in bulk
and like that's a key great start cuz
like yeah when I when I was a broke
vegan like the first time my first like
go around at it my like groceries for
the first of all I wasn't eating
probably enough cow
at the time but my groceries include
like you know a loaf of bread and a jar
of peanut butter which I wouldn't have
to buy every week or every two weeks or
whatever and I would buy salad stuff to
make a lunch with beans and you know
olive oil like a nice fats in there like
I'm getting a bunch of different fruits
and vegetables not a lot of carbs except
from the beams and the bread for
breakfast or coffee bean burritos and
then for dinner sometimes it was like
rice or beans or more vegetables like it
was an okay diet it wasn't enough
calories I was certainly was not cooking
dude I mean so I feel like you can be a
broke vegan and eat vegan food but
you're not doing like a ton of vegan
cooking you know like all this stuff
that we make at this point with like
you're making cashew crema like that is
like so expensive
vegan budget [ __ ] but like that it's not
a vegan budget but there are products
that you could buy hopefully and where
you live if not they are available
online but I totally understand what
you're saying and like I have a budget
and I don't I can't buy a bag of [ __ ]
cashews that's insane but like you can
get you know if you do if you are more
into like cooking dinner you can get
cheap seasoning cheap sauces and then
you know cook yourself some rice and
beans or variants of that with different
vegetables or proteins or whatever
yeah the basis though Kim doesn't have
to be expensive your produce and your
carbs can be simple and not expensive
especially the beans and rice if you're
willing to like soak them yourself
incredibly cheap yeah yeah you get the
beans dry you can feed yourself
incredibly cheap is that practical for
someone that's like maybe in school or
yeah I don't know but you can save more
money not that a can of beans is really
gonna stretch your budget either but in
addition there are channels on YouTube
who do specific videos for vegan options
and like I got no money but I'm hungry
and I want to eat animals I've only
found these videos because I was just
like watching one video and then
recommended another and then another I
don't even remember names of the
channels but there's so many [ __ ]
great huge you guys out there for advice
on how to feed yourself on a budget yeah
being so more than we could tell you
it's totally possible and it's totally
doable even if you're in [ __ ] nowhere
and there's not a Whole Foods within an
earshot yes and you think you can't be
vegan I've like literally been blown
away when we go to those small towns yes
we meet people and they're like I'm
vegan and I'm like [ __ ] yeah you have it
way harder than I do yeah you do it a
lot of it is just figuring out how to
make stuff for yourself and you don't
have to make them expensively with
expensive ingredients yeah that's true
also Taco Bell baby vegan options over
there not even joking look it up yeah
and you also don't need all of the meat
and cheese substitutes you can do a lot
of that on your own with just some time
but it's it just takes effort like any
other diet you know what I mean it takes
effort whip well I think that was a
sufficient advice cast hopefully you
guys got something out of this and if
you didn't just make sure you subscribe
because you might next time that was
pretty good I probably got us a couple
slobs right there cuz you might mix that
yeah if you didn't get something out of
it now you never know when you will
especially if you don't subscribe thank
you guys for hanging out with us for
another week we'll see you guys next
week for another episode of the Jenna
Juliana podcast you guys have a
wonderful week and we'll see you on
Twitch
[Music]